-Our next guest is the lea
political correspondent
for "The Atlantic"
and the author of the new book
"Battle for the Soul:
Inside the Democrats' Campaign
to Defeat Trump,"
which is available now.
Please welcome to the show
Edward-Isaac Dovere.
How are you?
-Hey, Seth. How are you?
-It's nice to see you.
-Thanks for having me.
-I actually have been
interviewed by you in the past
for a podcast,
so it's very nice for me
to be able to
turn the tables on you.
I see your book behind you
but you also have --
I think this is correct --
are those the campaign buttons
for all 26 Democratic candidates
in this last election?
-All 26 of them.
It was --
You know, I was traveling around
for this campaign.
All over the place -- 29 state
is what I ended up doing.
Iowa, New Hampshire,
all these places.
And the way that I tried to keep
my sanity was I was like,
"I'm gonna make a collection
of these buttons.
And so there they all are.
You can see the top one
is Marianne Williamson.
That's the craziest one.
It's her face.
Most of them are a little bi
more standard than that,
and it builds up.
I don't know if you can quit
see it in the shot
behind those flowers,
but there's a ticket
from the inauguration,
from the Biden-Harris
inauguration.
I felt like that was -- this i
what it was all leading to
so that's where it all goes to
-You chose to write this boo
in real time
as you covered the campaigns
as opposed to waiting
until it was over to write it.
What made you decide
to do it that way?
-So, I decided
to write this book in 2018
We sold the book in 2018.
And it said in the proposa
for the book
that publishers
were interested in,
"This is going to be
the craziest election
that has ever happened
and probably
the most important electio
in the history of America.
I knew that
that was the case already
without knowing obviously
anything about the pandemic,
anything about what happened
after George Floyd,
the economic crisis,
the democracy crisis we're in.
So the proposal got more tru
after I sold it,
but it was already clear
that the existential crisi
the Democrats were going through
once Trump won,
it's just such a crazy
collection of things
that were happening.
And I could see --
26 buttons up there.
I thought there would be max
16 people running.
But I could tell that these were
really interesting people,
and to get into these characters
and use them as way to tel
the story of what was going on
with the Democrats
was really interesting to me
and it made it so that
I didn't sleep a lot
over the last year
trying to do my day job
and writing this book,
but there it is.
-I think one of
the other things that people
wouldn't have predicted,
based on the early debates
is that we would end up with a
successful Biden-Harris ticket
You write a lot about how
they had some contentious
moments on stage.
Are you surprised
at how it resolved itself?
-Well, you go back
to that first primary debate
where she went after him.
Said, "I believe
you're not a racist,"
and then really
just clotheslined him
about his record on busing
And then the Biden campaig
was enraged by this.
And I report in the book
that Biden standing on stage
was so annoyed
about what happened
that he turns to Pete Buttigie
standing next to him,
and he says, "Well, that was
some [bleep] bull [bleep].
And Buttigieg doesn't really
know Biden at that point.
He's like, "Whoa!"
It's Pete Buttigieg,
who you've met.
Right?
It really hit him.
And the rage was so much
over this that
a couple weeks later,
I was myself talking to Bide
outside of an event
that he was doing
in Dearborn, Michigan,
and he was like,
"Oh, that's really nice,
not calling me a racist."
But what I got at in the boo
that I had not known until I
started reporting for the book
is that Jill Biden was
on a phone call
with some supporters
a little bit after the debate,
and she was so mad.
You forget sometimes,
Jill Biden,
in these elegant dresses,
underneath is, like,
the Philly girl, right?
And she said, you know,
"With the life that he's led
the work that he's done,
to stand up there
and you call him a racist?
Go [bleep] yourself."
[ Laughter ]
-So, they -- You know,
for people who might not kno
what opposition research
actually means,
but you write that, you know
based on this,
Biden went so far as to --
Did he go through
with putting together
opposition research for Kamala
-Yeah, these are research
that people who go through
tax records and every possible
public thing and private thing
a person's ever done with th
intention of finding bad stuff
And the Biden campaign
had not --
And, you know,
we can forget about it,
given all that's happened
over the last two years,
but this time, two years ago
the Biden campaign
was not in great shape,
and they did not think
to get a full
opposition research
about all of their rivals,
including Harris.
When this happens, they say,
"Uh-oh," and they right away
order from
an opposition researcher
who had already
prepared something.
Two days after the debate,
they say, "All right.
We're gonna need that,"
and paid a lot of money for it
-The book ends with you having
a conversation
with President Biden
but obviously not in person,
which is how
most of this reporting
would happen in a different era.
What was the timeline of whe
you were speaking with him
and what was that like?
-Well, so it's crazy, right?
It was COVID restrictions.
I spent a lot of time
covering Biden.
He's a very
hands-on person, right?
But we were over the phone
and we were on the phone
February 2nd.
The interesting thing about that
is that it was both
his late son Beau's birthday
as it happened,
and it was right before
he signed the executive orders
that got rid of
the Trump executive orders
So at the end of the
conversation, he said to me,
"I got to go. I've got to sign
these executive orders.
This is important."
I said, "That's fair."
But when we got on the phone
and it was a little bit
of chitchat,
and I said to him,
"So, what's it like?
Have you gotten used
to being in the Oval Offic
and waking up upstairs?"
And he said to me,
"You know, the Oval Office
I've been here a lot.
I was here almost every da
for eight years, but upstairs,
you know, I sometimes
can't find my clothes.
Nobody told me that moving
was part of this, man."
[ Laughter ]
And I said to him --
Because I don't know,
it's the way I am
in interviews with people.
I said,
"Well, you're the one
who wanted this job."
And he said to me, "You know
someone said to me I'm lik
the dog that caught the ca
after running for so long.
He says, "No, I caught the bus
I'm the dog
that caught the bus."
-[ Laughs ]
You also talk about, you know,
that there was this existentia
crisis with the Democratic Party
after 2016.
Obviously it caught
not just them but I think
a lot of people off guard.
Do you feel like the party
knows what it is now,
or do you feel like
they won this election by,
you know, a hair's breadth
and they'll be --
the same thing
will happen in the future?
-I don't think
the same thing will happen
but I don't think it's done.
It's not like the book ends,
and it's like, "The end,"
and everybody rides
into the sunset or whatever.
The best way that I guess
I could describe it is,
it's like the end of
the first "Star Wars" movie.
And I'm not a real
"Star Wars" aficionado,
but the Death Star
gets destroyed,
but that's not the end.
There's a --
The Empire is still there.
There's another Death Star
that gets built.
Part of what's going on
in this book is explaining
what happened
over these four years,
all the things that were going
on in the Democratic turmoil
And some of it's resolved,
and some of it is not resolved
at the end.
And, of course,
Biden and the Democrats
didn't do as well
as they thought they might
They thought that they wer
gonna be in a clear win
in the Senate and that
they weren't going to lose
as many House seats as they di
in November,
and that in itself is a bi
problem for the Democrats
and looking
what's going forward.
And then, of course,
trying to figure out socialism
moderates, progressivism,
what does Biden believe,
how do any of these things work,
and all of it with the midterm
already starting
to stare down at people.
-Also, I'd like to take a second
to say, it's still shockin
to me that the best "Star Wars
could do was come up
with a bigger Death Star.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, you should take
that up with George Lucas.
That's not for me, Seth.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you so much
for being here.
Congrats on the book.
It's really nice
talking to you again.
-Thanks, Seth, I appreciate it
-"Battle for the Soul:
Inside the Democrats' Campaign
To Defeat Trump" is availabl
now wherever books are sold,
but please support your loca
and independent bookstores